[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
All right.
Hey, everyone.
My name's Dan and this
is Matt, and we're
both Googlers who work on a
product called Dialogflow.
So I wanted to say first
thank you so much for coming.
We've been having
an amazing I/O,
and we're super excited to
share our talk with you.
You've probably heard a
lot over the last few days
about how important
the Google Assistant is
to our vision for
how computers can
help people get things done.
The Assistant works across
dozens of device types
and makes the most of the
best features of each device.
That could mean the
quick At-a-Glance display
of a smartwatch, and it
could mean the benefits
of no screen at all.
The Assistant is now available
on over 500 million devices.
So that makes this a
really important platform
to build for.
So the Assistant
is really smart,
and we've made it do
some super-cool stuff.
But the real power of platforms
comes from their developers.
So how do we empower
our developers
to extend the
Assistant and do things
we never could have imagined?
This is where
Dialogflow comes in.
We've taken what we
learned from building
amazing conversational
experiences,
and we've built a tool
that allows any developer
to do the same thing.
This session, we're going to
tell you all about Dialogflow.
We're going to tell you
what it does, where it fits,
and we're going to
show you how to build
a sophisticated action
for the Google Assistant
in just a few minutes.
We're also going to talk
about a few upgrades we've
made based on feedback we've
had from our awesome community.
So as you saw in our
developer keynote,
we've had really great
momentum in growth this year.
We've had half a
million developers
use Dialogflow, which
is a 250% increase
since this time last year.
And Google's developers
are obviously
really excited to use our
ML tech in their work.
We've also got brands all around
the world using Dialogflow.
And they're building some
really amazing stuff.
So if you want to see
some case studies,
you can check out website
to see some of our partners'
experiences using the product.
All right.
Let's get technical.
So before we go further,
let's go over some basics.
An action is a third-party
experience for the Assistant.
And there are many ways the
user can invoke your action.
First, they can just ask the
Assistant for your action
by name or maybe the Assistant
might suggest your action
based on its functionality.
Once invoked, your
action is going
to hand-- the Assistant is
going to hand the conversation
control over the Dialogflow.
Dialogflow understands
conversational language,
and it will hold a conversation
with your users based
on a structure that you define.
You can then connect this
conversation with your business
logic to make things happen
and generate replies.
To define this conversation,
you'll use Dialogflow's UI.
And there's a web app that
even non-developers can use.
There's no coding
required for simple apps,
and it takes literally minutes
to prototype a conversation.
Under the hood, this all uses
Google's machine learning
and natural language
understanding tools,
but you won't need a
PhD to make use of them.
For more complex actions,
connecting actions
with your code is super easy.
And you can even use our
embedded Cloud Functions
to Firebase Editor.
You just tell
Dialogflow at which
points the
conversation it should
communicate with your code.
Dialogflow then
makes an HTTP request
with JSON describing
what the user wants.
And you can use this to
construct a complex response
or to look something up and
generally make stuff happen.
So we want to show
you how easy it is
to get started with Dialogflow.
And over the next
few minutes, we're
going to build an
action from scratch
for an imaginary local business.
Our business is going to
be a bike repair shop.
Our action is going to work
like a helpful store clerk,
and it's going to allow our
bike repair shop's customers
to check the shop's
opening hours and book
an appointment to
service their bike.
So here's what's going to
happen during the demo.
First, we're going to
walk you through how
to respond to user queries
with a powerful concept called
the Intent.
We're then going to
show you how to extract
detailed information from user's
queries like times and dates.
And we're going
to demonstrate how
to connect your action
to business logic that
will store appointments
in a Google Calendar.
Finally, we're
going to integrate
our action with the Google
Assistant and test it out.
So to get started, I'm
going to hand over to Matt,
and he's going to
demonstrate how
the finished action
is going to work
on his shiny new Pixelbook.
MATT CARROLL: Thanks, Dan.
Can we go ahead and
search for the demo.
Oh, there we go.
So before we get
started building,
I'm just going to give you
guys a quick demo of what
we're going to build.
So right now on the
left side of the screen,
we have the Google Assistant
up on the Pixelbook.
And we'll say talk to my bike
shop to invocate our action.
So right now, the
Google Assistant
is handing off the
conversation from the user
from the Google Assistant to
our action, the bike shop.
So right now, we're going
to set up an appointment.
And it's going to ask us
what day we want to come in.
So we're going to
say next Friday.
And then it asks us what
time, and we'll say 3:00 PM.
And right now,
the Cloud function
is actually adding an
event to our calendar,
you can see there, and asking
us what kind of appointment.
So I'm going to say tune-up.
And there we can see our action
has confirmed the appointment
and has ended the conversation.
So now let's build it.
So we're going to switch to
this Dialogflow here and log in.
So this is Dialogflow's console.
On the left, you'll
see a panel where
you have all the main
concepts that you
need to use to build
a Dialogflow Agent,
and in the middle we
have the panel where you
use all these main concepts.
Right now, it's a
list of intents.
And on the right,
we have a simulator
where you can try out
your Dialogflow Agent
as you're building it.
So let's go ahead
and try it out.
We'll say hello.
So we can see that
the default Welcome
Intent here was matched.
And if we open up to the
default Welcome Intent,
you can see that we
have the response hi.
So that's not quite
what we want to say
since we have a bike shop.
So let's change that
response up and say
welcome to my bike shop.
How can I help?
So we'll try it again.
And no, we needed to add--
so now we're adding
a training phase
here so that our hi
query is understood.
And the agent is
training and using
this hi example as
a training phrase
for a machine
learning model that's
running in the background that
will identify incoming requests
to this Welcome Intent.
So we'll try hi again.
And now we can see that
our response is correctly
identified, and we send
back the correct response.
So let's create
our own Intent now.
So we'll go to the
Navigation Panel on the left
where it says Intents and
click this little plus sign
to create our own Intent.
And we'll type in hours.
So this will be our
Intent that we're
going to create
for any intention
that the user has to know the
hours that our bike store is
open.
So for the first thing we need
to do is add training phrases.
So these training phrases
are used as the basis
for the machine learning model.
So we need to think
of things users
might say when they want to
know the hours of our bike shop.
So I'll do a few examples here.
How late can I come in?
They might say what
are your hours directly
or they might say
when do you open.
So I'll go ahead and save
that and then Dialogflow
will start this training process
using these training phrases,
and while that's happening,
we're going to add a response.
So down here, we
click Add Response,
and then we'll say we're
open from 9:00 AM to 5:00 PM
every weekday.
We'll click Save, and we'll
try querying this out.
All right.
Are you open now?
So now we can see the Hours
Intent was matched down here
and sent back the
correct response.
We're open from 9:00
to 5:00 every day.
And now I just want
to take a moment
to notice that the
query, are you open now,
isn't really similar to any of
the training phrases we have.
When do you open, what are your
hours, how late can I come in?
So this is the kind of
the power of Dialogflow
and really shows off
how powerful it is.
If you can imagine trying to
write a regular expression
to match every instance
of these four examples
as well as the
thousands of other ways
that someone could ask
when is your store open,
this is where Dialogflow
just becomes really powerful
and allows your
users to talk to you
in a natural conversational way.
So now let's take a closer
look at the response.
It's a little bit generic.
So we're open from 9:00
to 5:00 every weekday.
We're not actually answering
the question, are you open now?
And in a normal
conversation with someone,
you'd expect to have more
contextual information.
So they might say, oh,
we're open until 5:00 today.
So for that, we need to do
some sort of calculation
as to what the time is and
if that falls within our bike
store's open hours range.
So for any sort of calculation
or API requests or database
query, we need to use
something called Fulfillment.
So if we go to the left
panel here, we see down here,
we have Fulfillment.
So Fulfillment is how you
connect your Dialogflow Agent
to code.
In this case, we have an inline
editor where I've already
deployed some code.
So we can scroll down here and
look at the hours function.
We check if the store
is currently open.
And if it is, we give a response
that says we're open now,
and we will be open until 5:00.
And if it's not, we tell
them when we're open next.
So there's one
more thing we need
to do to connect this code
to our Dialogflow Agent
and that's go back
to our Hours Intent
and scroll all the way down and
go to Fulfillment and enable
Fulfillment for this Intent.
So once we do that, if
we try our query again,
are you open now, we can
see right now that this--
so right now, the Hours Intent
is calling the web book,
and it comes back with
the correct response of,
we're open now, and we
close at 5:00 PM today.
So that calculation was made and
sent back the proper response.
All right.
Now let's try something
a little more complex.
We're going to create an intent
for making an appointment.
So we'll call it the
Make Appointment Intent.
And for this Intent, we'll
need a few more examples,
because there's many different
ways that a user might say
I want to make an appointment.
So we'll go through
those right now.
I'd like to get a bike tune-up.
I'd like to schedule an
appointment next Thursday.
Can I schedule service for noon?
Can I set up an appointment for
my bike tomorrow at 2:00 PM?
And the last one, I'd like to
come in at 9:00 AM on May 11.
So now you can see we
have a few things going
on here that are different
from our previous example.
So Dialogflow has
highlighted a few
of the entities that are present
in our User Says examples.
So entities, and Dialogflow
has several entities
built in so we can extract
data from what users are saying
and use it for, in this case,
to schedule a bike appointment.
So all the red highlighted
items are times,
and all the yellow
highlighted items are dates.
So if we scroll down,
we can see that these
are listed as parameters.
So we have the date
and time listed
and the value that we can use to
present this in our responses.
So in this case, we
want to reflect back
the time and date the user has
specified so we can confirm
the right appointment time.
So we'll go ahead and
add a response here.
And say, great.
I've set up your appointment
for the dollar sign date.
So this takes the value from
what the user says and puts it
in our response and then
at dollar sign time.
So this will add the same
thing for the time value.
See you then.
We'll go ahead and save that
and then we'll try this out.
So I want an appointment
tomorrow at 3:00 PM.
So now you can see that
Dialogflow has correctly
matched the Make
Appointment Intent
and has extracted out
that tomorrow means May 11
and that 3:00 PM
means 1500 hours.
So this is also-- it's easily
parsable on our web book.
And it correctly inserts those
values back into our response.
So to actually make
an appointment,
we need a date and a time.
So we need to make sure
that the user provides
both those pieces of data.
So we're going to go
to the parameter table
and make both of these
parameters required.
Now, when a parameter
is required,
we can define a prompt
so that if a user doesn't
provide a date or a time,
we can ask them for it.
So in this case,
for day we'll add
a prompt that says what
day do you want to come in?
And for our time,
we'll add a prompt that
says what time works for you?
So let's try that out.
We'll say I need an appointment.
So now that we've matched
the Make Appointment Intent,
you can see that the response,
instead of our response
to defined here, we hit one of
our prompts that says what day
do you want to come in?
So we'll go ahead and
answer that question,
saying next Friday.
And what time works for
you, we'll say 11:00 AM.
And now you can
see that this has
been filled in
correctly by Dialogflow,
and we get the ultimate
response back there.
So now that we've set
up an appointment,
we might want to get some
additional information
from the user about
the appointment.
So we might want to know what
kind of appointment type.
So we'll go ask them
a question and say,
do you need a repair
or just a tune-up?
So now we need a way to capture
the answer to this question,
if they want a
repair or a tune-up.
So Dialogflow already has
these built-in entities
for date and time.
But you can also
create your own entity.
So we'll go ahead
and do that now.
On the left panel,
again you can see
we have a panel for entities
and another plus button.
So we'll create an entity, and
we'll call it Appointment Type.
And then we'll add entries for
our Appointment Type Entity.
So in this case, we'll have
a service option and a fix
option.
So we'll enter in the
first value, service.
And then we can also
enter in synonym values
for each of these entities.
So someone might not actually
say the word service,
but they might say another
word that means the same thing.
So we can define synonyms
that will map back
to this canonical value.
So instead of saying service,
someone might say overhaul.
They might say maintenance.
They might say a tune-up
or they might say tune-up
with a space in it.
And for our other
value, we have fix.
So someone might
say repair, mend.
They might say their
bike is broken.
They might say they have a flat
tire or they might say fixed.
So we'll save that.
So now that we have an
Appointment Type Entity,
we need to create an
Intent to capture it.
And in the case of
our Intent, we only
really want to capture
this Appointment Type
Entity after our Make
Appointment Intent has
been matched.
So we want to make
a new Intent that
only is matched after the
Make Appointment Intent.
So that Dialogflow has something
called Followup Intent.
So if we hover over the
Make Appointment Intent,
you can see there's the
Add Followup Intent option.
So we'll create a
custom Followup Intent.
So this new intent that's
listed here with that arrow
means that this Intent will
only be matched after the Make
Appointment Intent.
So we'll click that, and we'll
add some User Says examples.
So for this, we've just ask
the user if they want a service
or if they want
to fix their bike.
So we'll enter in some
examples of how users
might answer that question.
They might say, I need
a repair or they might
say can you service my bike?
So now you can see, as before,
with the built-in entities,
Dialogflow has correctly
identified our custom entity
that we just created.
Since we need to know
this information,
we're going to make
it required, and we'll
add a prompt for it as well.
We can service or
repair your bike.
Which one would you like?
So now for our
response here, it would
be nice to confirm our
actual appointment time
and date after they've said
what appointment type they have.
But as you'll see here
in the parameter table,
we actually don't have
the time or date here.
So how do we get this value?
For that, we're going to need to
dig in a little deeper into how
followup Intents work.
So Followup Intents work through
something called Context.
So once we added this Followup
Intent to the Make Appointment
Intent, an output context was
added to Make Appointment.
There are two types of a
context, output context
and input context.
Output contexts attach
a context to a session
after the Intent
has been matched.
So in this case, after our
Make Appointment Intent has
been matched, the Make
Appointment Followup Context
will be added to the session.
Next, let's take a look
at our Followup Intent.
For our Followup Intent,
we have the same value,
Make Appointment
Followup Context,
except instead of
the output context,
it's in the input context.
So this makes the Make
Appointment custom
or our Followup Intent,
only get matched
once the Make Appointment
Followup Context is
attached to the session.
So in our case, the only time
that the Make Appointment
Followup Context is
attached to the session
is our parent Make
Appointment Intent.
So this means that this Make
Appointment custom Followup
Intent will only be matched
after our Make Appointment
Parent Intent.
In addition to controlling
the flow and how
Intents are matched, contexts
also store parameter values.
So we can use the value of
MakeAppointment-followup
to reference the time and date
that we previously gathered
in the Make Appointment Intent.
So we'll go ahead
and do that now.
We'll say, OK.
We'll schedule a dollar
sign appointment--
so this is grabbing whether
they're fixing or servicing
their bike, just
like last time--
for-- and now we want
to insert the date.
So we'll do pound make
appointment followup
and then do dot date
at, and then we'll
do the same context
value dot time.
So this will grab our
time and date values
from the previous Intent.
We'll see you then.
All right.
Now instead of trying this
out on Dialogflow Simulator
on the right, why
don't we try and see
what this looks like
when you deploy it
to the Google Assistant.
For that, we'll look
again on the left panel,
and we'll see a page
called Integrations.
So this Integrations page
shows all the integrations
that Dialogflow has with other
chat and voice providers.
So you can use any of these to
deploy your Dialogflow agent
to your users on any platform.
For now, we're going to start
out with the Google Assistant.
And you can see some information
about how Dialogflow works
with the Google Assistant.
But for now, we're just
going to try it out.
So clicking Test opens up the
Actions on Google Console.
The Actions on Google
Console is where
you define all the
information about your action
like invocation name.
So for right now, we
say talk to my test app.
My test app is a special
name that's just for you
when you're starting to test.
But you can enter in
any name for your brand
once you get into
the Actions Console.
For now, we'll try with
just talk to my test app.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK.
Here's the test
version of my test app.
[DING]
SPEAKER 1: Hi.
Welcome to my bike shop.
How can I help?
MATT CARROLL: So
what's happened now
is we've invocated our action,
and that sends the request
to Dialogflow, which matches
the Welcome Intent, which
sends back the response
we defined earlier.
So let's try this out.
Can I book an appointment
for tomorrow at noon?
SPEAKER 1: What
time works for you?
MATT CARROLL: Noon.
There we go.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
I've set up your appointment
for the 11th of May 2018
at 12 hours 0 minutes
and 0 seconds.
Do you need a repair
or just a tune-up?
MATT CARROLL: So now we see it's
matched the Make Appointment
Intent.
And now we're going to try
out our Followup Intent.
So we'll say I need a repair.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
We'll schedule a fix
for the 11th of May 2018
at 12 hours 0 minutes
and 0 seconds.
We'll see you then.
MATT CARROLL: So now you can
see that it correctly identified
the repair word and
mapped it to the word fix.
So in our response it says,
OK, we'll schedule a fix,
and then also grabbed the
time and date from the context
to surface that to
the user as well.
So now that we've got
an action fully working,
I'm going to pass it
back to Dan, who's
going to talk about
some of the new features
that we've built in
Dialogflow over the last year
and some more features
I didn't get to go over.
Dan.
DANIEL IMRIE-SITUNAYAKE:
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
You should take a bow.
So yeah.
I hope that we've shown
you how quickly you
can build a really
powerful Assistant
action with Dialogflow.
In a few minutes, we've built an
engaging conversational agent.
We connected it to
our code, and we've
been able to deploy and
test it immediately.
And the really crazy thing is
that after review, this action
will be available on
over 500 million devices
with no install required.
People just have to say
the name of your action.
So conversational experience
is a pretty new idea,
and building your first
agent can be hard,
because there's a
whole set of concepts
that may be unfamiliar for you.
So we've built a lot of tools
that will help make it easier
to get started.
Dialogflow comes with
45 pre-built agents
that you can use as a starting
point when you're developing.
We cover a load of different
real-world scenarios
like setting alarms,
booking tickets,
and all sorts of stuff.
All you need to do is import
the Intent and Entities
and customize them to
support and suit your action.
In fact, every single
Dialogflow Agent
comes equipped with
over 50 system entities.
These cover common
concepts, including
numbers, dates and times,
amounts with units,
and geography.
Dialogflow can extract values
based on these concepts
with no additional work.
So you can understand
your customers
and help them get things done
without a lot of overhead.
We also have a growing
library of sample agents
that demonstrate how
to use our features.
And these are referenced
in our docs and on GitHub.
And for I/O this year,
we've added a new feature
where you can open the
sample with one click
and try it out instantly.
So this will deploy the agent
and the fulfillment code
so you can just customize it
and be up and running straight
away.
Speaking of our docs, we've also
built in interactive Dialogflow
Agents.
So you can play with
real-life examples
to help you learn
important topics.
We're regularly publishing
new videos and tutorials
to help you develop, and we
just published another brief
Getting Started video to
our Dialogflow YouTube.
Once you've learned
the basics, we
provide tools to help you
do really powerful stuff.
So Dialogflow will help you
extend your actions over time
so you can improve your customer
experience and performance.
For example, natural
conversations
branch in complex and
unpredictable ways.
Things that are discussed
earlier in a conversation
can have an impact later on.
And in the past,
conversational platforms
required you to hard
code everything,
which was really brittle
and difficult to do anything
to improve over time.
Fortunately,
Dialogflow's context
allows you to shape the
flow of a conversation
without having to predict
every possible twist
and turn ahead of time.
This can help you get beyond
the idea of a menu-based phone
conversation and create genuine
conversation between people
and computers.
Once your action's
up and running,
you'll have a ton of
logs of conversations.
And you can use this data to
improve your action's machine
learning model.
Our training feature
will show you
all of your past
interactions, and it
helps you assign them as
training phrases for Intents.
You can also create
new Intents when
customers ask for something
that you didn't handle.
Every feature we add is
guided by these three goals--
we want to create an
excellent full stack
experience for
our developers, we
want the best possible
natural language understanding
in machine learning,
and we want it
to be easy to
integrate and scale
across any
conversational platform.
We use developer
feedback to decide
how to evolve our
platform, and I
wanted to show you
some of the features
that we've added since last
year's I/O. First, we've
heard that you want better
insight into how conversations
are going.
So we've improved
our History view
and made it much
easier for developers
to see how their
agent is being used.
Now you can filter on
dates and platform,
and you can search through logs
to find particular interactions
that are noteworthy.
This will help improve
your debugging experience
and help you get to a better
agent design over time.
We've also been
working really hard
to support all the languages
that your users speak.
And today we support a total
of 21 languages and 9 locales.
We've recently added support
for languages including
Hindi, Thai, and Indonesian.
And we cover all of the
languages the Assistant
supports, plus more.
We've also added
multi-lingual agents.
So you can build one agent that
works for all of your users
across the world.
Many of our customers
have been asking us
for an Enterprise solution.
And so this year, we introduced
Dialogflow Enterprise Edition.
This brings Dialogflow
to Google Cloud,
which means you get
Enterprise-grade compliance
and customer support on
our Cloud Terms of Service.
So Ubisoft built their
personal gaming assistant, Sam,
on Dialogflow
Enterprise Edition.
And Sam was able to
understand and answer
88% of player's requests
in the first three
months of their beta.
So I hope you're feeling
excited to get started
building with Dialogflow.
There have been tons of really
amazing Assistant sessions
at this year's I/O,
and you can find
links to recordings of
them all on the I/O website
so you can enjoy
them at your leisure.
You should also make
sure you check out
our Codelabs, which will
guide you through building
your first action.
Your feedback is super
important to our team.
And we really hope you've
enjoyed this session.
So we'd also love for you to
head over to the I/O website
and let us know your thoughts.
It's super easy to get
started with Dialogflow,
and we put together a page
full of links that can
help you get up and running.
You'll also find links on
there to our online communities
where our whole
team is hanging out,
and we can help
answer your questions.
Also, don't be shy about
tweeting our AoGDevs hashtag
if you want to share your I/O
experiences with our team.
So we hope you've had
a really amazing I/O
and that you go on and have
a ton of fun building actions
with Google with Dialogflow.
Thank you very much.
MATT CARROLL: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]